okay so hello everyone thank you so much
for coming today
for those of you who are either new to
demise or who are from outside of de
maiz and it may not be familiar with the
style of this talk my symposium
presentation today will be a sort of
research and progress talk and an
opportunity to tell you about the
research I'm really interested in before
I actually give my dissertation before I
propose my dissertation project okay
so first I'll present the question or
actually sort of questions that got me
started and then most of the talk I will
focus on prior work that other
researchers have done to address some
aspect of my original question and then
lastly I'm going to share with you some
gaps in the field that I might be able
to tackle in my in my dissertation it
would be immensely helpful to me to hear
us it would be immensely helpful for me
especially when it comes to the research
gaps to hear what does or does not
resonate with you and why so obesity is
expensive uncomfortable and deadly so
along the x-axis on this graph is body
mass index with relative risk of deaths
on the y-axis and as you can see for the
curves for both men and women the
relative risk of death increases
substantially with a BMI above 30 and as
you can see from the arrows across the
top this comprises nearly a third of the
u.s. population
okay so naively I started with this very
simple model of obesity greater food
intake and less physical activity lead
to obesity I'm not here to argue against
the first law of thermodynamics and
while I hope everyone here can
appreciate this very simple model
working model of obesity that it's
technically correct I I'm gonna propose
to you like is it really useful and I
would argue that it's not if it were
everyone would eat healthy food and move
and wouldn't gain weight
so despite being a very ardent champion
of Occam's razor this model is too
simple which leads me to my motivating
question for today which is why exactly
isn't this model of obesity more useful
so to answer this question I first try
to address what combination of
environmental exposures and common
genetic variants do we think cause
obesity in humans and in the process of
answering this question I also began to
wonder whether the reward system might
be a useful theoretical construct to
learn more about the cause of obesity it
is my hope that the answers to these
questions might lead to rational
prevention and treatment strategies okay
so I know it seems like very simple but
I think it's always good to start with
definitions so what is obesity and how
is it measured so overweight and obesity
are defined as abnormal or excessive fat
accumulation that may impair health and
this definition comes from the World
Health Organization and it's the body
mass index or BMI is a simple index of
weight for height that is commonly used
to classify overweight and obesity in
adults however BMI which is defined as
kilograms over a metre squared is just
one of many measures of obesity BMI
along with the other measures of weight
relative to height on the top bar all
make the underlying assumption that
excess body mass is from fat so the
remaining measures on this chart do not
make this assumption and instead attempt
to quantify a person's fat mass separate
from their fat free mass so while and
then the density based methods along the
bottom especially with the underwater
weighing that's considered the gold
standard when it comes to measuring
obesity so depending on the researchers
primary question he or she will use a
method that best estimates the amount
and location of fat or adipose tissue on
the body and often times BMI is
sufficient and a practical measure of
obesity for studying health especially
at the population level okay so back to
mine mine I
model if I were to if I want to better
understand the cause of obesity I then
wanted to say like what useful
complexity is missing from this model so
first I want to propose that we add some
important environmental exposures so
namely individuals that have access to
food may be individuals must have access
to food and we're going to actually eat
it so to understand how food access
affects food intake I want to show you
two studies that I found really
interesting and helpfully address like
how food access really does influence
food intake so the first the first study
attempts to predict actual foods people
eat given a cost constraint and the
second the second uses a measure of the
level of poverty in the area where the
study participants actually live to
predict BMI so the first study
demonstrate that cost adversely affects
food intake so how did they come to this
conclusion
so to conduct the study the author's
collected food intake data from 1,100
people through a dietician administered
survey in Paris and the author's
simulated how a reduction in total food
budget shown on the x-axis here as a
cost constraint and euros per Joule
would affect food intake based on the
actual price of different foods using a
retail food price database so to be
precise given the method here the
objective was to design a diet that most
closely resembled the meaning diet
observed in the population while keeping
the total energy intake constant so it's
basically like trying to keep like say
like what would a rational individual do
given that their budget is decreased so
from this simulation they found that a
reduction in total food budget predicted
a smaller proportion of energy from
fruits vegetables meat dairy products in
an increase in energy from cereal sweets
and added fats then they quantified
using the food composition database how
each lower cost diet would affect energy
density percent energy from fat and
vitamin C content so as you can see from
the three curves so percent energy from
fat as you go down reduce the total
budget but percent fat C is actually
pretty constant but the energy density
increases substantially and the amount
of vitamin C in decreases substantially
and for each of the diets depending on
the cop total cost and so they chose
vitamin C mostly just because that's
like a measure of good measure of like
micro nutrient content of the diet and
then energy energy density is another
well-known of whether a marker used in
nutrition research for whether or not
that's highly associated with earlier
death so okay so and these results are
oh yeah okay so so the next video i want
to tell you about shows that genetic
risk for obesity disproportionately
affects people living in areas of
poverty so this study was also really
interesting so along the x-axis here is
a genetic risk score for higher BMI
where people with a score of 10 have the
highest risk have a collection of
genetic variants with the highest risk
for obesity and the people with a score
of 1 have the have a collection of
genetic variants with the lowest risk
for obesity and then actual BMI is it is
plotted along the y axis so as expected
people with a higher genetic risk score
for obesity you have a higher BMI like
the positive term that you see very
obvious but the important thing to know
is that the 9 Atun of the effect is much
worse for people living in areas of
poverty so shown here the lack if you
read the lack of black by the black
circles these people have these are like
SVG stands for studio economic position
and to to determine whether people
actually lived in an area of poverty the
authors mapped each individual's postal
code to where they were from
that was done like using the postal
codes this study was done in UK so they
had they collected this information and
the level of poverty in each postal code
was determined using like oniony with
all the meaningful measure of poverty
which is which was the Townsend
deprivation index which measures like
the amount of unemployment non car
ownership non homeownership and
household overcrowding in each postal
code okay okay so I really liked that
study however I found this paragraph in
the method in the method section a
little confusing so the obesogenic
environment refers to an environment
that promotes gaining weight and that is
not conducive to weight loss here we use
the term environment to refer to any
variable that describes the component to
obesity that is not genetic variation
many of these measures are likely to be
a complex mixture of environment and
behavior okay so the reason I found this
a little confusing is because we know
behavior and environment are different
things and there is a tendency to sort
of lump them together so perhaps we can
improve our model of obesity by by just
separating them out okay
so I want to take you through now some
important landmark studies so I feel
pretty happy about the like adding the
food access so I want to take you
through some important landmark studies
that show how genetics affects obesity
okay so this is a question we're asking
so the first thing to recognize is that
some people are obese due to a mutation
in a single gene a trait is just for
like some definitions and he's everyone
in the room number a tree is monogenic
or Mendelian if a genetic variant is
both necessary and sufficient for the
trait to be expressed given the normal
range of human genetic and environmental
background variation in human genetic
environmental backgrounds so how do we
know that obesity is monogenic in some
people so first we find first we found
through patient family histories of
obesity that the inheritance patterns
looked Mendelian and so by Amanda Lee
and I mean that they followed one of the
like five patterns that you probably
learned about in high school so
autosomal recessive or dominant
excellent recessive or recessive or
dominant or Y linked so over time using
animal models of obesity that have
Mendelian inheritance patterns we were
able to figure out what these genes
actually are through positional cloning
and we then confirmed that these same
gene mutations we then confirm that
these C mutations characterized mice
were also in real families with
monogenic obesity using linkage analysis
okay so the so thing at all is the like
the author who first published the
positional cloning to map the first
Mouse obesity gene in 1994 which codes
for the hormone leptin which is right
here and leptin is released from the
adipose tissue in proportion to the
amount of fat mass which then acts on
the leptin receptor here in the
hypothalamus and to regulate food intake
so a number of other groups mapped each
of the genes involved in what is now
known as the leptin melanocortin
signaling pathway and importantly
subsequent linkage analysis of severely
obese children demonstrate the
demonstrated that genetic variants in
the Melinda Holton for receptors or
something like the blue circles is the
most prevalent form of human monogenic
obesity and you can see from this lick
sequencing panel that the genes we test
for in patients with suspected monogenic
obesity today encode important proteins
in the what in the leptin Villena corn
pathway and those are okay so it's also
very interesting to note that BMI in a
general population in this case about
them about five thousand five hundred
thousand people is associated with more
common genetic variants in genes that
are part of the left to Atlanta Courtin
pathway so we can see this relationship
in the figure here so BMI categories are
a call across the bottom on the x-axis
and along the y-axis is the proportion
of people in the population the 500,000
people with two or more common genetic
variants in the Molina court and pathway
and you can clearly see that there are
way more there are way more obese people
with common genetic variants in this
pathway then that been been in lower BMI
category so okay so this suggests that
the genetics that contribute to BMI even
in people without Mendelian inheritance
patterns for obesity could be okay so we
think that common genetic variants
contribute to obesity in patients
without Mendelian inheritance patterns
any genetic epidemiology parlance we
would call obesity a complex trait so
what exactly is a complex trait it's a
trait where the cause in a single
individual could be due to a single
genetic variant many genetic variants
entirely environmental or some
combination of genetic environments the
genetic variance and environmental
exposures so how do we know that obesity
is likely what how do we know that
obesity is likely caused by a mix of
genetic and environmental exposures in a
population so to do that we ask we first
ask the question is there evidence that
the trait is at least partly genetic in
a larger population and if so what are
these genetic where are these genetic
variants actually located so I'm gonna
do a little because I think it's fun and
helpful to understand so twin studies
consistently show that approximately 80%
of the variation in BMI can be explained
by a variation in genetics this table
shows the correlation in height weight
and BMI here here both at baseline and
at 2025 years followed up and here at
the first time when that people were
like around 20 years old and the
estimated hair of the herd and each of
these two columns show the inter pair
correlation between the first one this
is
monozygotic twins two people who share
all their genetics and guys I got the
twins which are it's like said Billings
but should hair should theoretically
should be assumed to be sharing half of
their half of their genes and then G is
a calculation of heritability based on
like I said based on this assumption
that guy psychotic trends are how share
half their DNA and monozygotic twins
share all three things so I think it's
like interesting just like look at this
right like see body mass index is here
around like 20 years old and 84% at 25
years later no these are just twins yep
so adoption studies show the importance
of genetics and not the environment
obviously a little bit of a strong
conclusion that the author's made but
let's roll with it for a moment
so adoption studies in general are
considered the gold standard for
disentangling the genetics and
environmental factors so how does an
adoption study work so researchers
identify a Co are adopted and then they
simply compare their BMI to the BMI of
both their biological parents and their
adoptive parents so in the figure above
the like weight class of the Doc G's is
here and here and then the body mass
index of the parents either biological
parents or adoptive parents are here
so what I hope is fairly obvious is that
the correlation in body fat and body fat
and body mass is a pre strong
correlation for the adoptees and their
biological parents and that that that
relationship is not strong for these the
adoptees and their adoptive parents okay
so I well I don't think this study rules
out a role for the environment obesity
want obesity it does demonstrate that
the genetics is surely important
so in order to find out where these
genetic variants are located research
started researchers started looking for
chromosome regions associated with
obesity and they did so by using
genome-wide linkage analysis that's what
they did first and findings from these
studies mostly re identified regions
that we sort of already you from
autogenic obesity at least from my
background research and in this study in
particular genetic markers in the reason
containing the manticore in receptor
were shown to be associated with BMI and
a percent body fat measured by like
biomedical electrical impedance analysis
so this region here I should put on
which like like when they actually
reported it the first time around they
just said this region of the chromosome
but later it was shown that that's where
the receptor was okay so with a
sequencing of the human genome complete
researchers were next able to ask if
there were any common genetic variants
associated with obesity genome-wide so
the first studies identified fat mass
and obesity associated or FTO gene so
while people who were like sort of
underwhelmed that at the time because
there was not any clear explanation as
to why FTO was associated with obesity
it was actually pretty cool since it
suggested that there are other genetic
mechanisms responsible for obesity in
humans aside from the leptin Mullane
according pathway so since 2007
genome-wide association studies for BMI
waist-to-hip ratio and lots of other
adiposity traits have identified more
than 300 single nucleotide polymorphisms
related to obesity but you can see that
a number of tips that are located close
to genes and associated with BMI here is
in the middle body fat waist-hip ratio
visceral adiposity extreme obesity birth
weight even this sort of little
different
yeah so that's sort of like the state of
the field for genome-wide Association
studies and I'll be sitting okay so that
was sort of long but I think kind of
Ness is a necessary tangent so we can
all be on the same page about how
genetics contributes to obesity however
we know that all these genetic how do do
we know that all these genetic variants
affect obesity directly so what if these
variants actually affect the behaviors
that lead to obesity like this I think
this would be important to know if we
have any hope of preventing or treating
obesity genetics of genetics associated
with variation in physical activities
outside of the scope of my child today
but probably very interesting so the
reason I became really interested in
looking at this and looking at the
genetics of food intake rather than a
boost obesity alone was due to another
interesting perspective published by a
group looking at a complex of separate
complex trait so specifically lung
cancer and this group was interested in
understanding the way genetics and
behavior contribute to lung cancer so
when they started they knew that smoking
causes lung cancer and they also knew
that specific genetic variants labeled
here from a previous genome-wide
Association study were associated with
lung cancer but upon further
investigation to the known mechanisms of
genes of these genes were where these
variants were located the authors
reasoned that most likely the most
likely explanation for their association
with lung cancer was actually due to
their effect on smoking behavior so does
anyone have any guesses so what these
variants are
so they code for the nicotine
acetylcholine receptor seven units so
they're hot and they're highly
associated with people's response to
nicotine so while it's definitely still
possible for these various tweaks or an
independent effect on the risk for lung
cancer I hope you can appreciate that
most if not all of the genetic variation
of these genes probably exert their
effect on one cancer through smoking
behavior so so I thought could this
framework apply to obesity and food
intake genetics okay so to evaluate
whether this might work I first needed
to look at the literature to see if food
intake is at least partly genetic and if
any of these genes variants have been
identified sort of the same questions
that I asked for obesity so while this
is there's been no gold standard
adoption study of food intake to date
that I could find twin studies on food
intake do indicate that the trait is at
least partly genetic but it should be
noted that the heritability as seen from
this summary table are definitely less
than the heritability of obesity so here
like long it's probably most rigorous
ones the most optimistic so what about
the locations of genetic variants
associated with food intake so
genome-wide linkage studies as with
obesity identified chromosomal regions
that are part of the leptin Atlantic or
pathway however few genome-wide
Association studies have been completed
the however the very few number of
genome-wide Association states that have
been completed on food intake have shown
some some novel variants so I put these
two together because they basically used
the same data sets
um and showed the same results though
that's why they're like the same thing
and then these two were two other
studies and returned so again FTO we
already knew
obesity fgf21 was a new finding and then
these students were also associated with
this was a confectioner antek was like a
survey and fat intake okay okay and then
so I when I first started looking at
this I was like oh I'm so good to like
make sure this is true and don't be done
I get in the UK biobank dataset so I was
like oh I should do that and then that
came out last month but it's good that
the results replicated so both SEO and
fgf21 were replicated in the larger
cohort and they also found two others
that I didn't put up here but I just
want to show you that like those who
were like found again and another
actually another three separate
populations that were included in this
study what was sort of confusing or not
confusing but just interesting it's that
like this issue of like looking at
different macronutrients and how how
these variants are sort of associated
with a mix mat mix mash of which which
which macro nutrient so humans get their
energy from fat carbohydrate protein and
also alcohol and these macronutrient
intake these macro nutrient intakes as a
percentage of total energy are
correlated to some degree because we're
eating foods that contain somewhat
conserved relative amounts of these
micronutrients so since we're talking
about genetics I wonder is there any
evolutionary theory that might help
explain why genetic variation would
contribute to food and macronutrient
intake so taking a step back and first
addressing the evolutionary theory
behind body mass index I'm going to
review this quote
so for survival mechanisms must exist to
preserve from us
agility of the hunter or in different
circumstances well padded padded energy
reserves to withstand famine but I think
the the point that I want to make here
is that although the language is flowery
this idea that the prevailing theory is
that why most animals including humans
have relatively consistent body mass the
sort of it sums up why people think
humans and other animals have a pretty
consistent body mass across the
population so what does this mean like I
like to go for more so it means that
over time our bodies have mechanisms for
making sure that we don't get too skinny
so that we can survive periods of
scarcity and while and and also that
there are mechanisms to make sure that
we can also don't don't get too heavy so
we can make predators and catch prey so
however humans in our sorry so it's
pretty like well accepted that this
compensatory measure for keeping us not
too skinny includes the leptin melina
court and pathway and that there is a
catabolic signal over feeding that's
theoretically theoretically keeps us
from becoming to to gaining too much
weight so the big catch in this however
is that humans and our most recent
ancestors have had very few predators
and little trouble catching prey since
we started using fire around 1.8 million
years ago and as the theory goes this
catabolic signal has undergone genetic
drift or random mutations not subject to
selective pressure
so is the theory backed up by
experiments so the short answer is yes
in the interest of time I'm not going to
go into the like particulars of this
mouse study but the authors did a really
good job of demonstrating that this
catabolic signal of overfeeding exists
in the blood and that it works
independently of the one the left in
Mullane according pathway however
exactly what that blood one factor is is
still a mystery and you can match in it
would be even harder to ping down in
humans because of the research engine
that exists so this is sort of my theory
but it's just a theory that potentially
like fgf21 and the pathway that it works
in which is only very preliminary like
being described in molecular studies
could be could play a role in this as it
could play a role as this sort of
catabolic signal of overfitting
so the reason I think that is that the
genetic variance in fgf21 are associated
with protein intake this endocrine
hormone is released from the liver it's
induced in the circulation by protein
evolution so if you have a diet that's
like very low in protein and alcohol
intake and it acts on the fgf one
receptor beta Clotho co receptor in the
brain and currently there are analogs in
clinical trials for food intake and that
reduced food intake decreased body
weight improved lipids and thankfully it
like so far there's very few side
effects aside from diarrhea but and very
few CNS side effects which is
predominately the problem with other
obesity drugs so it's sort of full here
is I sort of my takeaway has been that
it's probably safe to assume that there
that genetic variation contributes to
macro nutrient and food intake to some
meaningful degree in humans but to what
degree sort of unknown at this time okay
so now I want to know how does this
genetic variation in food intake relate
to food access so even though there has
been
drift over the last 1.8 million years
humans have only grown more obese in the
last 50 years or so and importantly only
1/3 of them have become obese not
everyone
so what genetic theory can help us
connect your theory help us with this -
so without access to a Western diet and
I'm like not defining this year so I
know that that peoples have a stay in a
very tight range just above the slower
intervention point and this can be seen
by looking at the very tight range of
the Emine in today's hunter-gatherer and
subsistence agriculture or communities
okay so however with access to a Western
diet which I realize I haven't defined
here a third of humans gain weight over
time so what some people gain weight
faster or younger I guess you could say
could genetic variation in the reward
system in response to food intake be the
reason behind this so there are more
than 20 regulatory gut and adipose
hormones that have a wide variety of
functions related to food intake and a
number of reviews really nice reviews
have pointed to the potential
relationships between some of these food
intake hormones and chemicals signaling
pathways in the brain
both attention is usually given to the
endocrine effects on the new opioid
pathways and the dopamine pathways since
they have been extensively studied in
animal models of reward system deficits
such as substance use and addiction we
have evidence that these two pathways
are relevant in obesity obesity control
in humans - as a combination of
naltrexone and bupropion are currently
used to treat obesity though there is
much room for success with with that
treatment however the main takeaway is
that while there has been
and provocative work in this area no one
has really systematically studied on a
human population scale whether a genetic
correlation exists between food and take
reward and other reward system deficits
so this group however decided to take
the idea of food addiction and just run
with it instead of measuring the genetic
correlation between food intake and
reward system deficits this group tested
a theater for the association of common
genetic variants and a food addiction
score and they basically did this by
adapting the substance use disorder
criteria and surveys to it just like
sort of substitute like food I mean it's
a little more involved than that but
they basically like if there's any food
where you sort of have like the feelings
of of craving etc they would like rate
you and then they looked at your
genetics genome-wide they look at the
German I've seen a lot of all the
participants okay
so so they said that in there they had
found two that were that reached genome
I'm genome-wide significance and they
were neuro trim them and protein kinase
C alpha they said in their results and
conclusions that they had no obvious
roles in eating behavior the only thing
I could find literature was that that
neuro trim them they said this later
there was something said that it was
close it was a closely related family
member to the opioid binding protein
which is potentially interesting and
that protein kinase C alpha is linked to
memory capacity and healthy subjects and
to risk of PTSD and genocide survivors
which was like really random but
interesting okay so they they're sort of
this like yeah it's a picture really
appropriate here so I'm gonna read you
this um this is like a commentary in
endocrinology nature of you so the
concept of addiction is loaded with
connotations and it's often used for its
political as much as its medical utility
the hedonic or reward system can account
for the ingestion of foods
drugs confirming that they share neural
substrates that differentiate liking and
wanting these are normal processes that
are recruited for natural homeostatic
behaviors and it can explain the
phenomenon of hedonic overeating as a
consequence of human motivation push to
extremes by an obesogenic environment I
don't know I just like felt this was
like a really good reflection and I'm
like you know before like how how to
sort of like study these concepts and in
a way that really helps us understand
the biology but sort of being aware that
like this research has done like not in
a vacuum and that there's like a lot of
is it really appropriate to you be using
the term addiction in this context so
then I want to ask like what actually is
addiction so from the American
Psychiatric Association the DSM their
definition is that addiction is a
complex condition a grayness ease that
is manifested by compulsive substance
you use despite harmful consequence so
they couldn't really come down on
whether it was a disease or a condition
and then as for whether it's the
substance use they've recently also in
the dsm-5 included non substance related
disorders under the heading of
substance-related and addictive
disorders it's very confusing but this
is what it is right now
thank you for clarifying that reasoning
for me it's awesome Thanks
yeah I mean I don't know yeah okay so
now I'm gonna get to the part of the
talk my to the research gap are the docs
think we have some time which is great
okay so so the research the first
research gap that I was interested in
looking more into of the 300 or more
common genetic variants associated with
obesity which are mediated through high
fat and/or sugar intake um and I had
like was interested in the high fat high
sugar intake because it was very simple
and I think it also can address this
issue of whether or not palatability
it's a word that sort of thrown around
in in this context and whether or not
that really has legs to stand on I think
is something I still need to like think
about more so the data that I would use
to answer this question is available
through a great resource called the UK
biobank it's a group of 500,000
individuals that the that UK has
collected data for and it includes from
a dietary perspective it includes five
cereal 24-hour recall half computerised
half dietitian sort of helped surveys
and and then it also has genotyping data
for all for all the participants there
the the food of the 24-hour recall data
is only for about 200,000 people but
that seems like an appropriate skill
that could be useful in this context and
then the possible method and I'm like
attention if you can put this up because
I'm not like really for yet would be
using structural equation modeling to
get out the answer to this question and
then the limitations a very strong
limitation with this sort of already
alluded to is that I really like
simplicity it's so one measure for sort
of a combination of high fat and/or
sugar and low protein intake for
sacrifice necessary complexity to sort
of disentangle what's really happening
and I got sort of interested in this
like geometric framework for nutrition
so that was like one one idea that is
sort of like percolating my head and
then the second um research gap that I
was thinking about was the hopefully
sort of obvious to people from what I've
discussed today is that what is the
genetic correlation between high thought
and/or high sugar intake and other
reward system deficits and again I the
UK biobank also has data on alcohol
intake tobacco use cannabis use and then
probably the there are data available on
other substance uses but they're not
quite as easily coded in terms of liking
use for me but it's not impossible to
use and then some possible methods that
I just sort of would be like the most
basic would be an le swirl regression or
a polygenic risk or Association but
these are very these of these methods
have serious drawbacks because of just
like confounding so they're just pure
correlation so you know there could be
reasons why you know like somebody could
be over there eating a lot because these
well that's the munchies a lot like
that's not really very useful and so but
the idea would be that looks something
like this where you could sort of
evaluate like on
Ruska like are there is there any
genetic correlation between food intake
and of high fat or high sugar intake and
any of these other substance uses and
then the last got that I was thinking
about was what are the relative
contributions of food access and common
genetic variants in reward pathways on
food intake as soon and that assuming
they are actually cause you causally
related Li can we actually quantify the
like the relative contribution and so
again I'm like I said I'm kind of like a
bank but I could also use food
composition databases or in Christ
databases or like in this case will be
probably more appropriate to use the UK
equivalent to look at this and some
possible methods up there again very
preliminary and but like obviously
because I'm saying I'm coming in with
the assumption that I think that they
that those associations are really true
I you know the burden would be on me to
like say like the assumptions that I
that I decide may be invalid and may be
less important to the community so yeah
so at the end of my talk but I would
really like it since there's time to get
your feedback and like what things seem
like wishy-washy or that you think are
really exciting what you would want to
know in this area
[Applause]
personally you know I'm really
interested so that's great talk thank
you but you seem to be relying on
structural equation modelling as your
proposed methodology okay which means
that all of a sudden you've got a
limitation on the number of calories you
could look at how one how are you gonna
screen for that and to I just as a
question how is our mental health
indicators could have commanded this
because if you have number K T being
mentally you know it's very very high
predictor of obesity so great question
okay so the first question was about the
founders see I think I'm like so so
there's sort of this balance right it
like these like very agnostic approaches
or just like oh the association here
you're sort of limited by like you could
you know you could do model adjustments
for making sure that like you know you
add some variables that you think are
important but like really you're you're
gonna have this problem of confounding
and like if you make the leap to doing
structural equation modeling and I may
be speaking out of turn here so I'm just
going to say that that that like being
really thoughtful about like what things
from the literature really indicate are
really like we think would be very
important in terms of like choosing
which confounders to include I mean
obviously like there's no like perfect
way to do that and it would be like you
know I'd obviously have to like do a
seriously review to make sure that like
whatever I choose and like to stand on
its own I against like the community
oh then your second question sorry and
then
I can answer that I know people so I
know people at so I've looked at them
looted cardiovascular disease and then
after the mental health question yes I
mean the the time issue is paramount
right it's like if we had if we had you
know time course yeah like that would be
ideal and in this case like you know
what came first the chicken or the egg
right like how does mental health affect
both of these things like you know it's
a loop right but I been thinking about
this problem
I feel like ignoring it is not good but
just sort of like throwing up your hands
and saying like oh well it's a loop so
we'll never figure it out I don't know
I'm still like weighing that and
figuring out like whether or not I think
that it would be helpful
so this this [ __ ] is just not include
children
it does include their percent weight
percentile at HK and I think to attend
rate so that's like something that could
be helpful Christmas this is awesome
I want to just dive into one very basic
piece of this for a second which is how
are you intending how are you
envisioning doing the actual phenotypic
classification
right I mean are you you know you say
high-fat sugar intake you know let's
talk about obesity right as your like
main outcomes and main inputs here and
fundamentally how do you envision
actually you know getting a handle on
that like a hundred percent like oh yes
this is the way I should do it and I
think like as my questions get more like
clear I'll have a better and better like
sense of like which how exactly at what
measures I'm actually going to use I
think in terms of like asking the
question about food intake and its
potential overlap genic overlap with
various like reward deficits I think
that BMI is a good as a better marker
than say something like a better mugger
to use because we know that it's more
like centrally regulated versus some of
the feel like fat distribution outcomes
that are but but even for something like
BMI right like are you going to draw a
hard cutoff at something or are you
going oh yeah um that was my like
the last time we were talking about this
we were talking about the gold standard
distributions
yeah and whether or not he could
leverage the gold standard measurements
to arrive a little better power yeah I
have thought about this a lot more - and
there was like a really nice paper done
like a long time ago once there like
four years ago actually the person who
invented let's see
okay so the person who did Ben's index
right it was like me and there that sort
of madness ya know like theoretically
right you could like fit your like
giving your population that you end up
using you could try to like fit the
curve exactly to the population there my
Occam's razor to me feels like like
slipped in like you could do that like
language yeah and like it's mostly used
in children so like there's this like
balance of like wow I've been doing why
the heck are you doing that or LR is not
a way to reduce noise in your data set
so what's interesting too is that on a
subset of the population they have like
they do have some of these other more
rigorous or moral standard but they
don't this method they have biological
bilateral impedance analysis for a
subset of people so yeah I I have an
inclination to stick with the line just
because I feel like it's easily
interpret one especially like if I am
going to do something like that's you
know already kind of like confusing my
including like confounders and like
stuff like I want to be more easily
interpretable so I'm not like sure
whether I would go that route but it
might be interesting at least for me and
my analysis so look at it I hope you can
justify doing the calculation this way
it might provide you yeah I agree
thank you in from a pediatric
perspective there's a lot of interest in
food insecurity and I imagine this kind
of ties into the the stress pathways and
I had to go back and look and remember
that that you've got the leptin pathway
is related to that stress pathway but I
just wanted to bring that up in me I
don't know if anybody's done any you
know genetic correlation correlation no
with response to food insecurity as
regards to any you know genetic mediator
but I think it's I think it's also
important in your modeling as you make
your primary assassins yes but but how
how likely it is that you'll have food
next month is different from how much
food do you have in total on average and
that's and that's an important factor it
has a lot of policy implications too
because people simplify it and say hey
well they're just eating too much right
so so so that and and the stress
response is probably a big mediator of
of that that's I just wanted to bring
that yeah I mean and that's like just
say too much about it because I'm not
like I wasn't come from behavioral
neuroscience training program but I've
learned a lot over the last like a few
months and the like the idea of like
liking right and whether or not liking
in terms of like reward is actually is
it always liking or sit just like relief
from like instead of being like this
feels good is it just feel not bad and
so if you all if you do have that like
elevated stress response like you know
the like what we call the reward pathway
I feel like it has to involve like you
know system and like you and your
threshold for all that stuff is probably
changing as I just dress changes and I
wanted to bring up also in relation to
that also
have you considered epigenetics in terms
of you know so you've got poverty over
six generations and so you got DNA
methylation yeah yeah so like that was
actually like that B's you know what
like of obesity like brought me to this
but at this time I I still feel like
there's enough unknown about just the
genetics
- really - then add the added layer of
like epigenetic regulation on top of it
I think at this population scale it's a
little pre-emptive right now but like
absolutely I would love to work on
something like that in the future thank
you yeah so um you've got a lot of
questions which kind of went into the
methodology and the symposium it's more
just remind people the proposal defense
it's much more about the gaps which I'm
glad you focused on I do think though
that you were it seemed like you were
really driven by the data set because UK
biobank came up in every possible
question and for some of the issues that
you brought up with Dion's
question one of the things you really
have to think about for that data set is
what is the clinical phenotype thing the
mental illness piece is actually huge oh
yeah so it's all self-reported I know
it's also because I'm saying so you have
to really think about that clinically if
you had things around self-reported meds
or something you might be able to do a
little bit more forensics but that's a
real concern there has been extensive
phenotyping in model organisms
especially coming from a behavioral
neuroscience perspective which would get
around that so you thinking a little bit
more about how to leverage that data it
doesn't mean you don't get to use UK
biobank but I think I would come at it
much more from the perspective of how
can you tackle these challenges in a
creative way that hasn't been done
before
yeah and then and then ask yourself you
know what are the data sets or other
things that are there because some of
that might help you get around some of
these issues at least kind of bootstrap
up into the very specific questions you
want to ask especially for the
structural equation modelling
Deanna's point was essential you have to
really think about what are the
different components there may be in
that model and so you being able to
leverage other datasets
to help get there would be something to
really think about as you're working on
your ah okay
so just on that point I just wanted to
latch onto that so in the case of
structural equation modelling would
having knowledge of priors in terms of
what might be good targets be useful and
could you scour the neuroscience
literature because we have a lot on on
using drugs to cause behavior as well as
knockouts to affect behavior and could
you potentially use that literature as a
way to kind of refine you know what
you're looking for in terms of what
might make sense as you know either for
priors or as a post-op sanity check and
your outputs since we do know a lot
about I think mine is not like that was
not my intention and I think that's
probably not like a good idea but that's
my response but I do think like using
like animal models and even like having
more of like variants that are in
specific pathways could be like a good
way also you're the third oh wow that's
loud the third aim is is is really a
possibly relate is about causal
relationships right so just our
curiosity are you
[Music]
[Music]
I'm saying can you say what that this
William
oh okay okay yeah I think that would be
like a very good way like I mean I mean
just like thinking off my head like Oh
gonna be good way to like for like
narrow down my like scope as to which if
I'm going to test things that are have a
lot of prior information in the
literature that would be like a good
resource to use as like so I'm not doing
just like sort of search I agree with
you thank you yeah those those yeah okay
so Josh just said that and while you
could also use animal model priors that
are associated with bore deficits or
deficits that you could also if if there
are into pathways available and anything
clear available resources that that
could be a good way to also narrow your
scope my scope us to like variants that
are enriched in those certain pathways
yeah
thank you everyone
I really appreciate your comments yeah
works just particularly through an
important receptors which also in fact
boxing hosts and signalling as well as
that's okay that's all I have to say
okay they memorize it useless it's
easily I for some reason though it's too
exhausting
so if you give rodents on tea to a
completely affects the food inside
dramatically